[Music]
have you guys ever lost your phone yeah
yeah yeah someone stole my phone how
long was it lost for some guy [ __ ] i
i don't know if you really stole it but
um i was shooting some content with
justin out at this um
like field and we're doing like these
sprint shots and i just tossed my phone
off to the side
and then later when we're done i was
like oh shoot the [ __ ] where's my phone
i have my phone cause i remember i
brought my phone
and then i'm like oh let's do that find
my iphone theme so i went on his phone
and it said it was at the park uh
bathroom
so i'm like what the [ __ ] so we go to
the park bathroom and then we reset it
or refresh it again and now it's on the
street moving away
we're like what the [ __ ]
so we got in the car and we started
following it and then when i finally got
close enough it said it was like this
old man that was walking on the sidewalk
and i was like excuse me sir
uh did you find a cell phone he goes yup
and i was like oh it's mine
he was like oh okay and he gave it to me
and then i was like where are you gonna
go with it he goes i was gonna turn it
in
and i'm like what the [ __ ] like there's
two people like there's no one at this
park there's two people and a [ __ ]
phone just on like five feet away he
never thought to ask like
hey is this is this your guy's phone he
was just like oh
he's like pretty much he went like this
[ __ ]
lost what i hope happened is he found it
and he's like god damn it all right how
far away is is lost and found he's like
17 miles away
exactly damn it
to do the right thing it's gonna take 17
miles out of my life
poor guys fine walking there yeah he was
walking i'm like what the [ __ ] dude
yeah but i thought it was stolen but it
was just the guy that was trying to turn
it in i guess that's the right thing
obviously bart obviously obviously yeah
don't criminalize again yeah come on so
uh this woman becky beckman lost her
iphone 10 years ago
and miraculously
found it
after hearing some funny noises every
time she would flush her toilet what it
was in her toilet yeah
it was inside the toilet how did it she
flushed it yeah i guess she had dropped
it in the toilet and then when flushing
it it kind of got lodged where you
couldn't see it but you could hear it i
could never flush this bad boy how big a
phone it was like iphone one or
something right 10 years ago it's 10
years ago so it's not the so that means
she dropped it in the toilet and she
didn't even know she didn't even know
yeah she lost it halloween night
probably meant she was like
drunk halloween night becky beckman
becky beckman
of course got a judgment for that huh
yeah
so she heads up they end up going like
dude the toilet they just figured the
toilet always made that noise when you
flush it like the rattling
and for 10 years it was just shaking
around right inside of that bowl pipe i
wonder what it looks like 10 years later
with all that water
oh
oh can you put a further back on the
scene yeah sorry i can't see that is it
too pixelated
oh that's better there's some dance
moves in front of it to make sure that
people can see it
i like how there's a picture of an
example of a phone being picked up like
it's like out of the toilet that's crazy
like it's not like all rusted or like
filled with [ __ ] well yeah and then i
mean i guess if you drop the phone like
today's phone in there it'd probably get
messed up but the old ones might have
been a little bit better the first
iphone was it's almost bulletproof heavy
that's all metal
that's a weight to it
do you guys forget like so after um each
phone cycle right like maybe like two or
three years or whatever
do you completely forget what your old
phone looked like or how big yeah yeah i
do once you see it again you're like is
i was using that isn't that crazy
when you see how big the screens have
changed over the years right yeah that's
what i won't forget is like the thumb
thing so like like it takes a tick i
have a big thumb anyway like the fact
that it takes a while for my thumb to go
from here to here is crazy because it
used to be just like
yeah you should be this little square
yeah it's funny to even complain about
that this is the actual actual phone
sorry that was the stock photo this is
it so the screen's not even cracked wow
let's see the let's see the other side
warp though that's like iphone 4. i'm
surprised it's not covered in cocka yeah
well no
it went to the top of the tank i guess
wait the top of no it was stuck in the
hole stuck on the s yeah yeah yeah
it basically split it whoa split the
dukes yeah yeah it was basically it
forked it like a bitcoin this is the
phone and this is the duke's that thing
was getting hit by the dukes every time
yeah man frank duke's straight through
the thing whoa splitting down
a terrible existence for that poor phone
they're just sitting there just just
just taking [ __ ] everything that the
camera was recording on in the toilet
and then you just see 10 years of
footage
you think the phone had to get used to
it at first so the phone's like
oh what's this going to be in the phone
it's like a brave little toaster oh no
it has a they should do a pixar film
others the duke guys
yeah it's like that one movie where they
got where you got stuck in a canyon and
you had to remove his 527 hours yeah but
it's the time it's the toilet it just
makes sense to me 10 years of splitting
kaka yeah he's like oh it's another one
oh that's pretty hard and he finds out a
way to like make some sound
or whatever his best friend's a dead
goldfish have you guys ever lost
something in like uh like something that
is worth a lot to you in like some
nasty situation you have to pull it out
no no no mine i think was the only was
just once uh my wedding ring fell in the
toilet oh i see what you mean and then i
picked it out and i think it would just
pee you know so that's not bad not so
bad that's not bad at all i actually and
i remember in high school i was uh
pooping and then i was texting on my
phone i dropped it in the toilet that's
pretty bad how did do you poop like this
is the dukey
this is what i did i went
yeah and then i went to the scene well
yeah this is the faster you do it did
you 10 seconds your phone still work
after no it actually when i uh dropped
it in there i heard it like vibrate so i
think it was like getting like water in
it and i'm a little disappointed at your
manual dexterity failure though with all
the [ __ ] you do yeah still dropping
phones in the cockpit yeah i forgot did
you
have enough time to wipe your ass too
before you see watch did you show no i
just i didn't even think i just went i
got to get it out like
i didn't think about it no i mean like
and then rinse out the thing where did
you run out of the bathroom with the
pants around your ankles and then i
think i did
but because nobody was there because it
was during class time i i went
her butt cheeks were were pressing the
little dookie that was still left in her
anus yeah i was waddling yeah that's a
good detail good detail
we covered that
you're in a public bathroom right and
then you're in the toilet
and then you take a [ __ ] and when you're
done you're like oh i should have
checked if there was toilet paper and
there's no [ __ ] toilet paper what do
you do and then you just wait and wait
and wait until there's nobody there and
then you [ __ ] open the door and you
rush to the next one and close just to
see that there's no toilet paper in a
second you guys don't know
about the pants shuffle the pack shuffle
what's the picture you keep your boxers
down you put your pants up and you just
[ __ ] did you say you keep your boxers
down and yeah your pockets are down it's
not touching your ass in your ass so
you're if you're actually oh this is
caked with [ __ ] [ __ ]
your box is down here
pants are on my ankles ass [ __ ] out
so i don't get [ __ ] anywhere and i was
waddling to the next
did you did you have a jacket though
no i didn't have it if you had a jacket
you could tie it around your waist yeah
if only we all had a jacket it's not a
perfect [ __ ] situation where did you
do this at school oh okay
i've done this in many casinos across
las vegas
is that where you're banned
yeah dude when i was in high school i
would be taking i remember the it was
like a freshman i was taking a [ __ ] and
i would go to the opposite bathroom
where i knew nobody would be in there
i go in there
and i'm sitting in there and then i just
hear a bunch of guys like rowdy as [ __ ]
come in and i'm like
[ __ ] because that's the worst feeling
yeah and they just started yelling like
who's taking a [ __ ] in here oh they
didn't take pictures of you someone's
taking this [ __ ] and they didn't [ __ ]
with me but they just kept slamming the
door and i'm like dude i was so [ __ ]
scared i was like oh ever since then i
never [ __ ] think of [ __ ] in the
bathroom why was that such a bit do they
still do that today
because that was such a [ __ ] but if
you're taking a [ __ ] oh it's just crying
today it shows weakness yeah you're
vulnerable but i can't hear you oh
you're
[Music]
bust your door open or take pictures of
you or that's like if you're in the
military and you used to be a model like
you just don't admit it
a child model is a friend who had that i
forget that that's something you have to
explain to girls like you know like guys
are so used to going to the guy's
bathroom and just anything can happen
and bring [ __ ] to each other yeah
and it's like the worst place to be
sometimes but then i totally forget that
women are like why you're all supportive
like i want to take a pass oh you want
to go i'll go with you
you know what blows my mind is like i
think all of us
trained ourselves to not [ __ ] at school
during school hours and if you really
had to go you went to the nurse's office
yeah i had to go it was a medical
emergency i'd rather [ __ ] on my backpack
for real
you would have your systems dude because
i would have some mad ibs dude smoking a
cigarette in the morning before school
and i'm in my first period like i am
going to [ __ ] myself
i'd be like teach i go the bathroom you
[ __ ] rush over but there's no doors
at the stalls man yeah so you got to go
to this individual ones thank god we
have bungalow [ __ ] right with the
individual glow [ __ ] oh you see if
like the one at the nurse's office
that's the one that we all went to yeah
i get some privacy yeah you go there oh
i didn't go oh my headaches just went
away yeah because i used to [ __ ] with
everybody that was taking [ __ ] yeah i
would honestly because i always had a
video camera around during all of high
school all four years i will [ __ ]
come and you record vlogging before we
shooting for the school like uh like a
montage or something right no i'm just
shooting for myself my own pleasure
i uploaded this whole thing of like all
four years of my high school and it's
like it's like a it looks like a vintage
movie and it's literally san gabriel
academy 997
to 0-1 that's dope a lot of that [ __ ] is
really just me hitting people in the
face with the camera because it was so
heavy back then
oh did they get bruises oh yeah they got
[ __ ] up oh man i wish i was at school
with you during that time i would have
got some good footage i got kicked out
i'm also the reason people didn't share
at school because i'll definitely be
with you
thank you [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
you